>> Tucker: FOR MORE THAN 100
YEARS THE BOY SCOUTS HAVE BEEN A
PILLAR OF AMERICAN LIFE, BUT
TODAY THEY ARE GONE, THEY
DISAPPEARED.
THE BOY SCOUTS OF AMERICA
ANNOUNCED THEY WILL BE CHANGING
THEM INTO SCOUTS BSA TO ANNOUNCE
THE DECISION TO ALLOW GIRLS INTO
THE PROGRAM.
GIRL SCOUTS I DON'T THINK OUR
ADMITTING BOYS.
ALSO A NEW AD CAMPAIGN ATTENDED
TO APPEAL TO BOTH GENDERS.
SCOUT ME IN.
NOT SURPRISINGLY SOUNDS LIKE ONE
OF HILLARY CLINTON'S MANY
CAMPAIGN SLOGANS.
MARK STEYN JOINS US TONIGHT FOR
A POSTMORTEM ON THE DEATH OF AN
AMERICAN INSTITUTION.
THIS FEELS KIND OF LIKE A
WATERSHED MOMENT.
MAYBE I'M OVERSTATING ITS
IMPORTANCE.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU ARE.
ONE OF THE INTERESTING THINGS IS
THAT BOY SCOUTS WERE SO
UNIVERSALLY PRESUMED TO BE GOOD
THAT THE VERY NAME BECAME A
SYNONYM FOR BEING A GOOD GUY.
TWO YEARS AGO, THE FIRST TIME
ANY OF US HAD HEARD OF JAMES
COMEY, 90% OF COLONISTS AND
COMMENTATORS SAID JAMES COMEY IS
RENOWNED IN WASHINGTON AS A
BOY SCOUT.
THAT'S WHAT IT MEANT, THE GOOD
GUY.
AND THE GENIUS OF THE LEFT IS
THAT IN NOTHING FLAT THEY TURNED
THE GOOD GUYS INTO THE BAD GUYS.
I REMEMBER GOING TO THE
DEMOCRATIC CONVENTION IN
LOS ANGELES IN THE YEAR 2000 AND
SOME SCOUTS CAME OUT BEARING THE
FLAG AND THE DEMOCRATS ON THE
FLOOR BOOED AND I THOUGHT THIS
IS CRAZY, THEY ARE BOOING
BOY SCOUTS.
THE DECISION IN THE '90s NOT
TO HAVE GAY SCOUTMASTERS.
COMPANIES LIKE DISNEY SAID THEIR
EMPLOYEES COULD NO LONGER GIVE A
CHARITABLE DONATION THROUGH
DISNEY TO THE BOY SCOUTS.
BASICALLY THE GOOD GUYS WERE
TURNED INTO THE BAD GUYS AND
THAT'S WHY THEY ROLLED OVER ON
TRANSGENDER SCOUTS, THEY ROLLED
OVER ON GIRL SCOUTS AND NOW THEY
HAVE DRIVEN A STAKE THROUGH THE
HEART OF THE INSTITUTION AND IT
IS DEAD.
>> Tucker: IS HAPPENING ON A
LARGER STAGE BECAUSE HARVEY
WEINSTEIN WAS A PIG, MASCULINITY
IS CRIMINALIZED.
SOMETHING IS LOST HERE.
I WANT TO ASK YOU, IT'S MAKING
ME SO DEPRESSED THAT I HAVE TO
MOVE ONTO SOMETHING HAPPY, I'M
SORRY.
I WAS NEVER EVEN IN THE
BOY SCOUTS.
IT'S ONE OF THE LAST WHOLESOME,
AT LEAST IN MY MIND, PLACES FOR
BOYS.
WHERE ELSE DO THEY GO?
>> I WAS A LOUSY BOY SCOUTS, SO
YOU COULDN'T HAVE BEEN WORSE
THAN ME.
>> Tucker: I WAS NOT
IMPRESSIVE ENOUGH TO BE A
BOY SCOUT.
I WAS SLOUCH SHOULDERED AND
LONG-HAIRED.
NANCY PELOSI ON A HAPPIER NOTE
SAYS SHE STICKING AROUND GARY ON
TUESDAY THE DEMOCRATIC LEADER
SAID SHE PLANS TO RUN AGAIN FOR
SPEAKER IF THE DEMOCRATS WHEN
THE HOUSE, AND THEY MAY.
REPUBLICANS LOVE THIS.
DEMOCRATS ARE TERRIFIED, BUT
HERE'S MY QUESTION, WHY ARE
DEMOCRATS SO AFRAID OF
NANCY PELOSI?
THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE A
SPEAKER BUT NONE OF THEM WILL
SAY THAT TO HER BECAUSE SHE
HOLDS THIS MYSTICAL POWER OVER
THEM, WHY?
>> SHE HAS SAID THINGS THAT
WOULD TAKE OUT ANY NORMAL
POLITICIAN.
WE HAVE TO PASS THE BILL SO YOU
CAN FIND OUT WHAT'S IN IT.
SHE'S IN FAVOR OF OPEN BORDERS
AND YET AT THE SAME TIME SHE IS
IN FAVOR OF MANDATORY
CONTRACEPTION USE SO THAT NO
AMERICANS WERE ALREADY HERE HAVE
ANY CHILDREN.
SHE'S A MASSIVE CONTRADICTIONS
AND INANE STATEMENTS.
BUT UNLIKE REPUBLICAN LEADERS,
SHE IS A RUTHLESS OPERATOR AND
IF YOU ARE A DEMOCRAT AND YOU
RUN UP AGAINST NANCY PELOSI,
IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK OUT TOO
WELL FOR YOU.
SHE'S SERIOUS AND SHE'S TELLING
THEM BACK OFF BECAUSE WHEN WE
WENT BACK IN NOVEMBER I'M GOING
TO BE THE SPEAKER, DON'T GET IN
MY WAY.
>> Tucker: A MASSIVE
CONTRADICTIONS AND STATEMENTS
BUT THE DAUGHTER OF THE MAYOR OF
BALTIMORE, SHE KNOWS HOW TO
COUNT VOTES AND SHE'S TOUGH AND
TOUGHNESS IN THE END IS DECISIVE
TOUGHNESS IN THE END IS DECISIV
DECISIVE.
DO THINK IT SORT OF A MEASURE
HOW WEAK A LOT OF DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS ARE THAT THEY ARE AFRAID
OF A 78-YEAR-OLD FORMER SPEAKER?
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE, SHE'S ACTUALLY
A YOUNG WHIPPERSNAPPER.
BERNIE SANDERS -- USE OF THE
BOY SCOUTS WERE 108 YEARS OLD.
I THINK BERNIE SANDERS WAS ONE
OF THE ORIGINAL MEMBERS BACK IN
WHATEVER IT IS, 1910.
SHE IS A BEAUTIFUL YOUNG THING
COMPARED TO MOST OF THE
DEMOCRATS.
>> Tucker: I THINK BERNIE WAS
A YOUNG PIONEER, FOR THE RECORD.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Tucker: IN HIS SPEECH TO
HIGH SCHOOL KIDS TODAY,
MICHELLE OBAMA SAID THIS, WATCH
WATCH.
>> I KNOW THAT YOU ARE ME AND IF
I CAN BE STANDING HERE AS YOUR
FOREVER FIRST LADY THEN YOU CAN
DO ANYTHING YOU PUT YOUR MIND TO
DO ANYTHING YOU PUT YOUR MIND T
TO.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE ME.
BROUGHT IT BACK TO ME.
BUT WHATEVER.
>> I DON'T ACTUALLY LIKE THE
IDEA OF -- THERE'S A TERM FOR A
FOREVER FIRST LADY, IT'S QUEEN.
AND I THINK THERE'S SOMETHING ON
REPUBLICAN ABOUT THIS.
WHEN I HEAR IT IN CONTEXT LIKE
THAT I DO WONDER IF SHE'S JUST
READING OUT SOME SAPPY SOFT ROCK
SONG BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT IT
SOUNDS LIKE.
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE ME, YOU ARE
MY FOREVER FIRST LADY.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
>> NUMBER 37 IN 1988, KENNY
LOGGINS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
JAMES TAYLOR, JOHN KERRY FLEW
JAMES TAYLOR.
YOU ARE MY FOREVER FIRST LADY.
IT'S A GREAT SONG BUT IT IS ON
REPUBLICAN.
I THINK THE BEST TERM FOR
MICHELLE OBAMA IS MRS. OBAMA.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN THIS PRACTICE
OF EXTENDING GOVERNOR AND
SENATOR TITLES FOR LIFE.
YOU ARE BETTER OFF WITH THE
DUKES BECAUSE TITLES LIKE THAT
ARE IN THE GIFT OF THE PEOPLE.
THE PEOPLE WITHDRAW THEM, YOU GO
BACK TO BEING MR. AND MISSES.
>> Tucker: AND IF YOU CAN'T
TAKE MY APPENDIX OUT I'M NOT
CALLING YOU DOCTOR.
A REMIX OF THAT SONG, I'M
SPEECHLESS.
THANK YOU.
>> IT'S A GREAT SONG.
NUMBER 37 IN 1988.
ASK CASEY CASE, IT WAS A HUGE